first they're always you take this
system and you need to translate it into
a matrix okay
so it has the same dimensions as our
previous one right so it's going to be
two rows three columns okay and I write
down my numbers like so okay so far so
good
and now the arithmetic begins okay so
you need to make some twisters just like
you do with normal simultaneous
equations as to well what might be the
most logical thing to do to modify these
rows so they play nicely together and
cancel things out that's what I want in
the end right so I suggestion anyway
take the top row and multiply it by two
I think that's a good call why is that
such a good idea why is that solution
why why is it so efficient is a better
question what's your next step add the
two rows together good okay so I want to
take the second row and as to the first
Oh
okay sorry let's pick up again I'm gonna
add this bottom row to the first one
watch okay
zero as you expected right six plus
negative one 528 plus negative eight
good in chair the rule you try to add
where you can because most people's
brains better with adding and
subtracting we get negatives mixed up
and so on okay and this row is the same
as before
okay one step to get this variable what
I do excellent let's divide through 0 1
4 so I solved one of salt one and I'm
gonna use that constant to solve the
other ones right now here's what they
call things by the way um you might
notice I wonder if any of you are
thinking man this method with matrices
is a pain because every single time you
do something you have to write all of
the equations right and I'll agree that
does slow you down a bit however the
immediate payback to that is that
because you're writing every row at the
same time every equation in the system
you can modify more than one equation at
the same time and that's all good all
the changes are being tracked right sir
rather than write this next line down
right as it was before I'm going to
modify it immediately what do you think
I should do with this word keep in mind
that this is the right got about I think
probably remember I'm trying to
eliminate I've got this once all so I
want to eliminate that from this next
word right so if I have one and negative
one here I should just add them together
okay so watch what happens
zero plus 2 2 1 plus negative 1 0 which
is what I wanted
ok and then it's 4 plus negative 8 which
is negative ok so you see matrices are
more powerful in that they let you do
arithmetic faster that's the payoff for
having to write more you can think more
as well
and now what do I do just divide it
that's all
and there are your two solutions a is
going to be negative for 2 and B is 4 so
I already pointed out one advantage
namely that you can do the arithmetic
faster right let me show you another
advantage have a look it up have a look
at what I've got in the right-hand
corner just put your pens down for a
second I've just made up this equation
this system of equations it's really
easy but I want to show you in common
problem that solving simultaneous
equation has particular when you first
learn them ok so for instance what makes
you do to this you might take this
second equation you might think well I'm
going to multiply by 2 and I multiply my
two is that okay so you get 2a minus 4 B
equals 2 it's not okay and I'm gonna
call this equation 3 now at the moment
this is all fine like I it's a very
simple question you haven't had your
brain clouded from all these other
questions you've been doing an exam and
you're not in a rush so you can do this
five what would you do with this you
would have 3 3 & 1 and they would
interact together ok ah however when you
don't get such a simple question and
when you are in a hurry and you are
making errors you'll do something like
oh wait I'll put together equation 3 and
equation 2 I'll do something like I want
to know 3 take away 2 months and to
write something like that and you say
okay that'll be super you are and I'm
like I must be it confused what went
wrong why did I just get no why am I so
upset okay what was the methyl adult
methodological problem with what we did
no seriously what did I do wrong can you
articulate it good yes exactly right um
if you didn't touch whether it said
you're a fine thing um even though
equation three and equation two are
different they came from the same place
they're equivalent right so you can't
put it back into yourself always you get
you know nonsensical things like this I
just don't give you any extra
information you never never ever ever
have this problem with matrices why not
think about it you'll never do this from
the matrix
aha
so remote how we're saying oh it's been
a pain you're going to wipe them out
every time every time you've got two
patients two questions two equations
right because you're writing out every
time they never disappear you can never
put a road back into itself there's only
ever one of it right so where as here
I've actually got two copies of equation
two that just look a little bit
different but they're the same equation
so that's why you can mistakenly put it
back into itself you will never do that
with a metric so advantage one you can
do arithmetic faster advantage too you
don't get confused like this advantage
number three when you make things bigger
they don't get harder I want you all to
try now and have a go at solving this
system okay write it out as a matrix
give it go